this is the go on sport Bible but we're
deciding once and for all what is the
greatest Champions League winning team
of all time the United sides they had a
lot of luck in that trouble they had a
group to day we pulled the sport B
audience asking them who they think the
greatest is and the top answers are on
this board now it's up to them two to
argue out and if they can't agree we'll
go back to our Poll for the deciding
vote we'll do that until there's just
one team left and who will be crowned
the goat Champions League winning
team so before we get into it of course
you're Arsenal and you are Spurs um you
don't exactly have the pedigree when
talking about this competition however
he's horrible I'm not having that coming
from a Brighton fan I'm not having that
I am a Brighton fan yeah we'll be there
next year it's fine so without further
Ado let's start we're going to start on
your side we've got Liverpool 2019
versus manad United 1999 of course the
treble winning side I mean for me no
offense Liverpool fans but it would
definitely be United 1999 as you said
treble winning side I mean to to do that
is just an unbelievable feat we're going
to talk about loads of teams have
actually managed to do that meanwhile
that Liverpool side were good though and
um the United side and I know you're not
United fans are going to come up come at
me now they had a lot of luck in that
treble and listen you need a lot of luck
to win these knockout competitions but
they had a gr for death yeah they had a
lot of luck getting through but that
Liverpool side I remember that final man
I am going for that Liverpool team right
because they saved my summer okay they
saved my because could have won it right
and you know yeah dodgy dodgy pen that
was never if it weren for them right it
would have been the worst summer of all
time imagine Tottenham would have won
the Champions League before Arsenal
right and for that alone I'm putting
them through no no way you I mean I'm
not even going for stats on this it's an
amazing team I can't I can't F that at
all and I'm not bit because of what
happened yeah no but for me you don't
argue with a treble winning team just
don't all right so you're going to lock
in m999 you're want to lock in 2019
Liverpool man so this is going to go to
the sportb audience so Liverpool overall
got 4% of the vote out all the teams
here okay Manny 99 got 14% of the vote
so unfortunately youve lost out on this
one Manny 99 99 are going through to the
next round that Liverpool team I still
got a lot of love for you man thank you
they going to live in your heart forever
now aren't they they do they too man
right next one we've got Barcelona 2009
versus AC Milan 2007 you know what
that's two great besides you know that
AC Milan team AC Milan used to be
dominant you know in Europe just like
what Real Madrid were weren't they I
mean that was a that was a great that's
some incredible players in zagi sof poo
Nesta Malini da some like Legends of
this is literally quite possibly one of
the greatest teams of all time 2009 that
is a great well yeah if I'm going to do
that I've got to say that b 2009 team as
well HRI T PUO Iniesta shaby etto buet
and again that's just to name a few also
that team first Spanish team to win the
treble I believe so yes yeah yeah it was
an amazing side it's just because as I
said we we're kind of sleeping a bit on
an AC Milan team because it was so long
ago but they were really really good but
I think I would Edge to the Barcelona
team so Barcelona side absolutely Bara
his first season in charge as well so
yeah pep guard the manager as well y
yeah all right cool lovely let's go to
and it was a started the styling which
it's rare we agree I know yeah we age
well the first one you definitely didn't
agree um the second one a bit easy
yeah I haven't got a vendetta against
United fans just remember that cuz I
have put you there but for me it's inter
because I hate to be like a broken
record but they did win a treble and
even though we can say what we want
about Jose the way he plays he had etto
as like an auxiliary right backer at
times but for me you just can't sleep on
that and what they achieved with that
team playing defensively but they all
knew their jobs they all did it well so
my vote Milan yeah you know what they
did shock everybody that year um because
nobody expected them to to go on and win
it in the
Milan that United team was very good I I
was about to say team consisted of
Rooney TZ skulls F and Village vanur and
they went unbeaten they didn't lose a
game they didn't but they weren't they
weren't they just weren't as potent of
me they weren't as the the most exciting
United version I think it has to be
United for me I mean that Mourinho team
that won he con of
ground it out in a way you know I mean
and I always remember the etto at the
back sort of thing that was crazy but he
pulled it off but I think the man united
team it's got to be our United side all
right so we're going to go to the the
audience vote the support bar audience
so they're definitely going to go united
you reckon what you reckon audience
going to go for probably United yeah
yeah okay so um the man united 2018 got
5% of the overall vote and the interlan
only got .5% wow that's so that's that's
not right that's not right take out with
the audience gu is not right guys treble
Winning Side that's she's for TR winners
but you can have it your way there we go
and then final one on that side we've
got Barcelona 2011 versus Porto 2004 of
course a fairy tale story the 2004 one
you know Mourinho sort of big breakout I
suppose for most European fans but that
was the breakout moment that was when he
arrived and for me that's why I go Porto
that was like I don't even if you'd see
that again like the way football right
yeah the way champions league has gone
with the money and everything like that
the the you know Porto for them to win
the Champions League yeah I thought that
was an incredible incredible achievement
it's got to be them for me I mean that's
just and even some of the Porto players
like cavalio Deco Ferrera went to chel
as well and obviously incredible players
in that's my pick as well I think just
from the magic of it and even though it
wasn't the hardest run that you'll ever
see in the competition still had to be
what was in front of you and I think the
way that they did it with that team just
magic yeah even though that Barcelona
side with Messi scoring 12 goals that
season the likes of Alves PK via Pedro
and beat beat M United 3-1 in the fin
you expected them to do that right that
season you expected them to to win the
Champions League that Barcelona team was
brilliant but the Porto team nobody
thought that they could go all the way
and it's such a huge achievement I think
it has to be them so you guys are happy
with thaty brilliant right so that side
of the draw is looking up very nicely
now we go to your side of the draw we
got Liverpool 2005 versus Ajax 95 this
is mad group this is crazy because
obviously the Liverpool one we all
remember that was east stol of
course magnificent comeback you know
against AC Milan you know what I mean
great team at the time but I actually
old enough to remember that Ajax team
and the stars in that team the players
hul it sof and players like that I mean
yeah we got van desar The Ball Brothers
Ed Davids Patrick clber CaRu was he play
for AR as well and F George some
incredible George incredible incredible
team and again you know um if that was
now you know probably Chelsea would have
bought half of that team you know you
know before they even get a chance to
win I mean yeah that's the thing now
when you get teams like that now they
all get picked off straight up I mean
all of those players did eventually get
picked off but they were able to keep it
together and I I'm this is going to be a
bit controversial because that Liverpool
victory was incredible you know
obviously the miracle of eastan buul and
all that but I just feel again I say I
look at the overall team the players
that were in that you know I remember
how good cliver was in those days and
scored the winner in the finals you know
18 years old youngest I think I go ax
yeah I'm not I'm not you know arguing
with you over it I don't actually mind
who goes through particularly in this
whole category because there are some
unbelievable teams uh with Liverpool I
mean that is probably one of the best
nights of football you'd ever witness
you know even as a neutral like the
miracle V tample speaks for itself it's
easy to say Liverpool cuz this was so
long ago but honestly if you look at the
players that they had yeah I saw s off
even in that um soccer raid thing he
still got it he's still bang and also it
was it was such a young team as well
that Ajax team I don't I I can't split
them so I think let's go to the audience
so go to the fan vote we know it's going
to be in it
it was a big big Landslide obviously the
sport our board mostly based in the UK
so I think we can see where this is
one's going but ax 95 side got 0.25% of
the vote and Liverpool got 7% of the
vote absolutely so Liverpool without
some of these teams should not be
getting .5% I think that was a strategic
move by uh Abby to save her reputation
amongst the scalers you know what I mean
it's hanging on with yeah right amazing
right now we got an all Real Madrid
Derby uh Real Madrid 2014 versus Real
Madrid 2018 the 2018 one was when they
beat City they beat PSG they beat Bayern
on the way to the final all Champions y
I think 2018 and also bicycle kick sorry
2018 sorry was the Liverpool 3-1 final
Liverpool 31 sorry 2014 was the one all
Athletico yeah yeah so Ramos got the
last minute equalizing that one so
obviously more dramatic in the final I
suppos a bit more comprehensive the 3-1
versus Liverpool and you also have Loris
Carri as well the bit of a mistake in
that final and then of course Bale in
that game as well scored the absolute
incredible goal one of the best goals
I've ever seen in the final8 2018 2018
for me 2018 okay looking that in nice
and easy love that okay Barcelona 2015
versus Real Madrid 2012 that's MSN
season isn't it yeah Neymar Messi they
were joint top goal scorers That season
with 10 goals a piece joint top goal
scores in the Champions League for for
Barcelona but then that's that's
galacticos galacticos yeah zadan go
Roberto Carlos ra part of that the most
ridiculous I'm going to go to I'm going
to go B to 2015 based on the fact that
the understanding that Messi Suarez and
neyar had was ridiculous um and that's
just my personal preference to be it's
purely on a football like obviously I
was quite young with the galacticos
anyway but I just remember that
Barcelona 2015 team being iconic
absolutely iconic always that Real
Madrid team galacticos again don't
really mind which way this goes rob you
pick do you want to go to the audience
right yeah let's go
audience save yourself I can't actually
separate them yeah okay again this one
was bit of a landslide to be honest with
you so real madri 2002 is a 75 of the
vote and Barcelona 8% of the vote wow so
Barcelona 2015 that was a great great
side okay now this one is a good one got
an all British classic here man city
2023 versus Chelsea 2012 I don't think I
think it's quite easy for me you know
winning the treble that means that
you've done it on all fronts you you've
been pressed in your own League
obviously we arel were up against them
but their domination in the Champions
League I mean that game against leig you
know what they did to Dortmund what they
did to Real Madrid I mean to me they
were just dominant absolutely dominant I
think if you got a team that's so
dominant they have to go forth on the
Chelsea side of things obviously I don't
like Chelsea but um I think there is a
big luck element in that Chelsea one I
mean you probably would have bet your
mortgage that IR am Robin and
Schweinsteiger scor their pens not
saying that you know didn't earn it but
um there was luck even you know the
Torres goal um right place right time uh
for him but I don't know for me I think
it's city all day long I can't I can't I
mean I don't think it's even fair to
compare the two sides for me there's no
there should even be an argument is city
all day long all right unanimous what we
honest much more agreeable on your side
haven't we we agree right let's go back
to your side over there we got man
united 1999 versus Barcelona 2009 you
going to go back to the treble winners I
was going to mention it but they're both
treble winners there's not much I can
redundant in I think this is pretty much
just down to how you like your football
played as we said five or six wins for
United Barcelona unbelievable peps ver
season first treble for a Spanish side
arguably one of the best teams of all
time yeah I I love that Barcelona team
the style of football you know I mean
they revolutionized the game so just
before you lock this in as the barcelon
I feel like you're agreeing now however
we' got to talk about the 99 final you
know of course you had solshine Sheron
come off the bench and win it for them
in in incredible style do you think that
counts for anything as an Arsenal fan
no it does it was a horrible moment man
I couldn't believe it and in that game
in that game as all they were getting
dominated they were you can't call it
luck because you make your own luck
right and it was a great great
incredible comeback right and you know
um s SC still a hero to this day for
them but um yeah and it was fantastic
comeback it was incredible but for me
Barcelona still Barcelona for me um when
it comes to the two sides agree yeah
nothing to argue with him over oh wow
that a burst isn't it it's I told you
it's so rare there very rare So Rare
right next one to get him into the semis
man united 2008 versus Porto
2004 I don't think we're going to agree
on that I still think it's
Porto I'm actually agreeing with you
because just the achievement of it okay
and and just the fact that you're just
not going to see nothing like I I can't
see especially the way the champions
league is going now it's more and more
going towards the big super clubs you
know what I mean and that achievement by
Porto Ian you look at PSG they how much
money have they thrown at it to win it
and they still haven't won it you know
City thrown a billion at it they've only
just won it they after trying and trying
and trying
that Porto side I mean that
achievement yeah for me it's Porto all
day long because those those moments are
just magical right let's get Porto
through God we're really agreeable let's
go back to this side of the draw
Liverpool 2005 versus Real Madrid
2018 you know what that Liverpool one
was a unbelievable
comeback you know I can still remember
it now like you we you said earlier that
was against a really really good AC
Milan team
the Real Madrid one was kind of expected
was it again that they would do that it
but we're talking I think it's more who
they beat along the way yeah we're
talking about the greatest teams of all
time in Liverpool's group just quickly
as well on the Real Madrid 2018 side we
had Ronaldo as a top goal score with 15
goals which is like incredible do you
think it came to a bit of a Reliance on
Ronaldo do you feel like the team had
enough with obviously see the likes of
Bale and Bena there with him as well
everything went for Ronaldo didn't it
everything went for Ronaldo and that's
what I'm saying like I want to kind of
put the Liverpool team through but if
we're talking about greatest of all time
teams
Ronaldo you know Real Madrid Champions
League their Champions League royalty
their Champions League royalty they have
to they have to go for it Liverpool to
be fair Liverpool Champions League
royalty as well yeah I mean they've won
many European cups but I think Real
Madrid have to go through yeah I'll go
I'll go Madrid yeah I'll go MADD without
further Ado Robbie can you please put
them through to the semi-final
right Barcelona 2015 versus Man City
2023 I'm going to go City I think
because of how unreal that achievement
was and they wanted it for so long and
how good that side was you know just on
the way there who they played score
lines it's it's that's a it's a
difficult one to call that both unreal
I'm going to go for Barcelona I I I
think um they were exciting you know I
mean when I think of those three up
front you know you would have been
shaking in your boots the face there
it's true that was an incredible
team
City it's a very very close so bitter
he's so so bitter yeah and and there a
fact that you know yeah listen
man yeah I hate this team you so you're
going with Barcelona Barcelona yeah 15
and you're going man city 2023 so we got
tie going to go to the audience vote Man
City got 88.5% of the vote ooh
and Barcelona actually got 8% of the
vote so City super close City make it
through they're they have both great
sides they really are you happy with
that to yeah I'm fine like I genuinely I
could have gone for either or like the
this whole side there is not much
splitting each team so I'm happy with
either well let's go to the first
semi-final then Barcelona 2009 versus
Porto 2004 barcelon now all day all day
long you know what I mean um Porto fairy
tale's not enough the fairy tale all
that but pure football football that
we've never seen before until that team
came you know um it's got to be
Barcelona for me changed the game pep he
really did he changed how we view
football and now when you watch football
and you think well you know gone of the
days of you know the long ball and
things like that it's because of Pep and
what he's done to the game yeah all
right well looks like this one's
unanimous this one very easy oh hello
breaking the board yeah let's not break
the board okay barel in our first
finalist and then we've got Real Madrid
2008 team versus Man City
2023 um I'm going for Real Madrid in
this one Ronaldo Bale
Benzema amongst a host of other players
modri what an incredible team City team
was great but I just thought that that
that Real Madrid team the Swagger in
which they did it in as well yeah um
yeah that mrid te wi that final yeah
yeah incredible incredible incredible
side yeah yeah I'm in agreement I also
go for Madrid for all of those reasons
listed um and obviously the journey to
the final as well for me cool all right
perfect fair enough right okay we have
got the El Classico El Classico El
Classico look at this Barcelona 2009
versus Real Madrid 2018 do you know what
I'll I'll put my neck on the line and go
Bara what was it about that 2009 side
was better than the 2018 side both
unbelievable teams unreal um but I just
think as we said at the at the start
like that's his first season in charge
he's the like the first team to win a
treble in Spain and he has changed how
football is played you know that is that
is Pep's Legacy that that is the purest
form of a pep team I've ever seen
obviously we see it now with City but
that is he changed the mold he broke the
mold and for me to do that in your first
season and win what he won with the
players also that he had
unreal I'm I'm actually going for Real
Madrid I I um I actually think like
any argument around the ch Champions
League they' got to come out on top they
that that game um if they played each
other would have been a really really
close game because of the players on
each side but there's something about
Real Madrid in the Champions League or
the old European Cup where they just got
that mentality that just gets them over
the line they've got that winning
mentality where you know remember that
the game against city um where you know
we all thought they were dead and buried
and they came back and won it's just
what Real Madrid just do that in this
competition over the years and for me
there's nothing to separate those two
teams because they Messi's on one side
Ronaldo's on the other there's great
players throughout from top to bottom in
both teams but I just think what would
have happened if if they played each
other that mentality that Real Madrid
have in this competition would have made
them win it so I'll go Real Madrid I was
going to ask we can't have a go
conversation without mentioning Ronaldo
and Messi and they're both in the final
now who do you think is more important
to their side in those sides there 2009
and 2008 Who do you think had more
impact um I would probably say who's
more important to this I'd probably go
Messi for Barca because when you look at
who was around you I mean don't get me
wrong they had unreal people in there as
well unreal players but I think for
Madrid you you're looking at that and
you're seeing benma and Bale you know
you're not even factoring who else is
behind them and who else was on the
bench so for me I think Messi was more
important to Barca so let's focus on the
finals as well of each respective team
so barcelon obviously beat an incredible
man united side arguably one of their
best ever sides in the final 2-nil that
night and of course Real Madrid beat
Jurgen Klo Liverpool 3-1 in the final as
well who do you think had the tougher
final I'm going to go to the Real Madrid
again because um that Jurgen Club
Liverpool team was in its um in its
prime then you know what I mean um they
lost Sal early on as well to that yeah
yeah that's what I mean again remember
there was a lot of people were saying
that possibly this could be Liverpool's
moment and they talked up Salah and then
as Real Madrid do they found the way and
next week you know salah's at the game
and they go on and win the final I I to
me I'm still sticking with Real Madrid
but then that man united side of course
for Barcelona was ridicul inredible they
were they were the holders as well as I
keep saying I don't want to sound
repetitive but it was Pep's first season
in charge and to win a treble and to
beat the holders of the Champions League
that is huge that's absolutely massive
but that's not convin to you you're
sticking with your guns I'm sticking
it's close but I'm
I also love this Madrid team I I I
really do right okay so we can't split
you we're going to go to the sport bar
audience that Barcelona 2009 side got
12% of the vote Real Madrid got 6% of
the vote yeah so barcon 2009 are Crown
the goat big round of
[Music]
applause
right the next one I know it's a bit
close to your heart obviously you're
good power a certain person on that
board and he works for him now as well
hilarious you going to do to your
bus you lot shouldn't have done this
that's naughty you shouldn't have done
this generator not random generator
random generator a producer knew what he
was doing and he did their job perfectly